ich bin gerade kurz beim Mute fürs Handy
Leute ich mache gleich ich habe auch
niemand an und schreib mir mal BITTE
pranks rein weil hier wird dann immer
sonst zu viel gespamt so komm rein ins
Geheimversteck bin drinne ach da rein
stimmt
falsche Wand falsche Wand Leser warte
hey warum komme ich denn was hast du
schon wieder gemacht dass ich nicht
reinkommen und du schon ich habe gar
nichts gemacht vielleicht hast Du
zugenommen in Minecraft ich ja länger
nicht bewegt hier muss ich irgendwas
drücken Leute
du hast das Bild abgebaut
ich brauche deine Hilfe
ich bin wieder da bei mir funktioniert
Video auf RTL nicht ja aber da habe ich
[Musik]
Luca bist du noch da
ich habe mich versteckt such mich mal
du hast dich versteckt
krass versteckt
ja du hast dich nur zu mir teleportiert
junge Scammer
ey was ist hier denn passiert
ja irgendwie ich glaube bei mir waren
Erdrutschen bei dir war irgendwie eine
Überflutung
ja ich weiß nicht dadurch dass bei mir
glaube ich hier so eine so ein von
Erdrutsch war ist das Wasser glaube ich
vom Damm nicht mehr zurückgehalten
worden was er die ganze Zeit dann auf
dein Haus getropft ist
wie ist denn das hier mit was bekämpft
man Feuer und mit was bekämpft man
dementsprechend Wasser
korrekt absolut nicht korrekt aber mal
schauen
ich habe ein Feuerzeug ja nur wenige
Minuten später
da passiert nichts dafür bin ich dumm
oder bin ich dumm und weiteres
tatsächlich
was warum bist du Weltall
was
wo bist du
ganz unten
oh mein Gott tschüss
da war wer da war ich nicht
ja das Gegenteil von Wasser ist Lava
hier du musst mit Lava oben drauf gehen
also muss jetzt oben auf dein Haus drauf
gehen und dann Lava einmal hinsetzen
ja ich rutsche hier nur von A nach B
an scheiße
[Musik]
warum hast du denn nur eine Ernst
abgrundtief gefallen wenn ja monacoym
gut mein Fehler so bin am schlafen aber
die Untertanen schlafen unten schön mit
Pfeilen im Körper und der König schläft
oben auf sein
Baumhaus also du bist wirklich Schütze
ne also Leute wir brauchen eine Glocke
und eine Leder pferderüstung die Leder
pferderüstung kann ich noch finden oder
wie viel Leder hattest du gib mir das
mal bitte gegen was ja okay was möchtest
du im Gegenzug
ähm
okay ein Stream wo du mich nicht tötet
und ich darf alles machen was ich will
aber jetzt nicht mit Finger kreuzen oder
so jetzt mal no joke auf Ernst ne ich
habe Finger nicht gekreuzt okay wie
schicke ich dir noch mal die Sachen und
wie kann ich dir noch mal weiter
schicken am besten per WhatsApp
zweite sind die Jahre später
nur ich brauche noch eins
eine große Nummer aber nicht mehr
okay nee kam wieder nur
hmm noch mal den großen nee nee nee nein
Scheiße verkackt
ich rasch komplett aus ich sage einen
töten du tötest ein und dann so den
anderen auch und in dem Moment tötest du
schon Sammy du hast irgendeine Krankheit
glaube ich du hast irgendwie so Trigger
werden bei dir dann aktiviert
[Musik]
ähm also unser Plan ist dass wir erstmal
noch die Sachen fertig machen die wir
fertig machen möchte ich möchte den
Pferdestall bauen sondern auch noch ein
zwei Pläne danach müssen wir uns die
enderperlen erstmal besorgen aus dem
Nether glaubst du ist meine
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich gewinne
alleine jetzt oder wie
0%
brauchen wir natürlich die enderperlen
um uns erstmal die Teleport Dinger dazu
machen und dann gehen wir
ins Ende und versuchen mit dem Ende
Drachen aufzunehmen
meine Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich das
schaffe liegt bei 45%
, dann wieder Schild und dann Schwert
und das bringt gar nichts machen denn
der fliegt
ja dann fliege ich auch ich fliege mit
dem mich nach Mallorca
gesagt sie soll sich mal auf den
heutigen Stream ein bisschen vorbereiten
weil wenn dann waren lange nicht live
wir machen extra mal XXL Minecraft dafür
haben die drei Stunden am Stück gespielt
und so und was kam Sandra hat nichts was
sie gerade zu tun hat sie kommt überall
hin was ich mache und in Minecraft hat
auch tatsächlich nicht mehr funktioniert
zu Beginn Shader hat sie auch nicht drin
luca du weißt doch bei mir ist alles
immer spontan also ich weiß auch nicht
warum das bei mir jetzt erstmal nicht
funktioniert hat
ach so ich dachte ja ich bin hierhin
gegangen und meine Ruhe von dir zu haben
ich habe hier Steine abgebaut du stand
plötzlich in mir drin ich konnte keine
Stein mehr bauen ich habe mir gedacht
okay alles easy sagst du nichts gehst du
hier rüber brauchst dir deine Stein ab
du kommst hier mit rüber stehst wieder
okay dann bau du ja ab ich gehe hier hin
baue hier wieder Stein ab und was
passiert du stehst wieder in mir drin
wir fahren jetzt zusammen in der andere
Insel dann schauen wir nach rechts da
sind genug Boote kommst du nicht mit
oder wie
wer kann weiter über die Boote rüber
springen wer kommt weiter also so weit
springen wie möglich von einem Boot uns
andere
mitgezogen habe junge okay
es war ja ein prank to Meyer
wie springt man überhaupt noch alte vier
Leute meine Frage was macht ihr auf der
Gamescom ja das ist für mich nämlich
auch so die Sache ich finde das halt was
macht ihr da ganz genau also
spielt ihr das spiele weil die Schlange
die Schlangen sind ja lang lauft ihr da
rum hoffen
also ich kann wirklich sagen was Serien
angeht irgendwie immer wenn wir sagen ey
stellt mal fragen kommen Serien Fragen
kein Problem wir sind eure Serienmörder
[Musik]
oh mein Gott ich dachte gerade so
Serienmörder von wegen Dir erleben die
Serien für euch und können euch dann
berichten aber Serienmörder sind ja
einfach Leute die ganz viele Menschen
umgebracht haben also das sind wir
tatsächlich dann doch vielleicht eher
nicht okay dann lass uns schlafen gehen
und dann den Stream jetzt auch beenden
also Leute ganz ganz viel Spaß euch hat
mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht heute mit
euch und wir sind wahrscheinlich so eine
Woche wieder live vielleicht doch schon
ein bisschen früher äh kommt drauf an
Wegen games und so
[Musik]